i've drawn an arbitrary triangle right
over here and i've also drawn its three
medians median eb median fc and median a
d and we know that where the three
medians intersect at point g right over
here we call that the centroid what i
want to do in this video is prove to you
that the centroid is exactly two-thirds
along the way of each median or another
way to think about it we can pick any
one of these medians and let's say let's
pick eb what i want to do is i want to
prove that eg
eg is equal to 2 times gb 2 times gb so
whatever distance this is it's twice
this distance there another way to think
about it is eg is two-thirds along the
way of e b and the logic that i'm using
to prove this you can use for any of the
medians to show that the centroid is
exactly two-thirds along the way of any
median or divide it into a segment
that's twice as long as the other
segment and to do that let's focus i
want to focus on triangle a b e
triangle a b e right over here and i'm
going to draw this median as essentially
the base so let me draw it that way i'm
going to try to color code it similarly
so
let me draw it i want to draw a little
bit flatter than that
so it's like that
and then we have the two yellow sides
so it looks something like this
it looks something like that and then we
have the centroid right over here at g
that is our centroid and we had this
magenta line going to a
let me draw a little bit neater than
that
we have that line going to a and then we
have this blue line going to f right
over here
we have this blue line going to f
and let me label all the points
go back to the orange color so this is
going to be e
this is going to be b
this is going to be a
this is going to be f right over here
and just to make sure we have all the
same markings that little marking there
is that marking these two markings
these two markings are on this side
right over there
and the whole way that i'm going to
prove that eg is twice as long as gb is
just refer to the result that we did i
think a couple of videos ago that the
medians divide this triangle to just sit
into six smaller triangles that all have
equal area so another way to think about
it is each of these three smaller
triangles have equal air these are three
of the total of six smaller triangles so
these three all have equal area so let's
think about this triangle right over
here
let's think about this triangle triangle
agb
agb this is triangle agb right over
there those are the same triangles and
let's compare that to triangle let's
compare it to triangle e a g
right over here let's compare it to this
triangle which is this triangle right
over here on the original drawing
now they both have the exact same height
if you view eg as their as their base or
not or their i guess their their shared
base it's not they don't have the exact
same base the smaller triangle has the
base
e sorry the smaller orange triangle has
gb as its base the larger blue triangle
has e g as its base but they definitely
both have the same height or altitude
when you draw it this way
so their height in both cases is this
right over here
now the other thing that we do know the
other thing that we do know is that this
blue triangle e a g has twice the area
of the orange triangle how do we know
that because it's got two of these
triangles in it so one way to think
about it is if this orange triangle has
area x
let me call it a well i already used a
so i'm going to call it area x then each
of these blue triangles have area x
or you could say this entire blue region
this entire blue region has area
2 x area 2x so if you look at this blue
triangle right over here we know that
one half times base times height is
equal to area so we get one half
the base is eg one half i'll do that in
the green color one half
e g
times height
times
this yellow height
is going to be equal to 2x
is going to be equal to 2x i'm just
i'm just applying the formula for area
of a triangle one-half base times height
is equal to area this is our area now
let's do the same thing for this orange
triangle
one-half
let me scroll over a little bit to the
right
we have
one-half gb
gb
times the yellow height
times height is going to be equal to x
is going to be equal to x
well we can substitute if this is equal
to x we can we can
place this entire expression right over
here for x so let's do that we get
one half
and you might already see where this is
going but i won't i won't skip any steps
here we get one half
times eg
times eg times h
times
h is equal to
2
is equal to 2 times x but instead of x
i'm going to write this here is equal to
2 times
2 times 1 half
times gb
times this length times the base of the
smaller triangle
times h
times h and now we can just simplify
this
we have 2 times one-half is just going
to be is just going to be one you can
divide both sides by h
and we are left with one half eg is
equal to gb
or we could write eg
over 2 is equal let me do the same color
since i've gone this far with the same
colors
so we can write we can write one half
eg
eg
is equal to gb
is equal to g
b
and we're done this is essentially
saying that gb is half of eg gb
is half of eg so for example if eg is 2
this is going to be 1. if eg is 4 this
is going to be 2. so we've actually
proven our result well actually let's go
back to this is the result we wanted to
prove to get to there we just have to
multiply both sides of this equation by
2. you multiply this the left-hand side
by 2 you get eg you multiply the
right-hand side by 2 you get gb so we've
proven that eg is twice gb and you can
apply the same logic to any of the
medians to show that the centroid is
exactly two-thirds along the way of the
median